yeah I think it makes more sense I think
it's a little more straightforward okay
but sometimes it's hard sometimes the
graph is hard okay sometimes you need to
do this okay this is a bit more
complicated though sometimes it's the
best way to go and whichever way you go
you know if you do want to do the other
I'll help you oh you got the right hands
up okay so think about it like this okay
you've got this this is the parametric
equation for x right now if I'm trying
to find the restriction on X in some
ways I ought to be able to work it out
just from this equation okay well the
question is how right
remember back I rubbed it off but we
worked out the PQ is equal to 2 right so
that means that Q is equal to pursuit on
P right now when I've got this I can put
that into here and now what I have is
really useful because this equation with
just X and just the parameter okay
just next is just the parameter now the
reason why it's important is because I
know that the parameter has to exist
there has to be some solutions that make
this work okay they like well what
difference is having okay let's do this
because this is all about quadratics
okay I'm going to turn this into a
quadratic equation but it's not a
quadratic equation in X is it why not
why not this is a quadratic but it's not
a quadratic of X why not because it's P
squared there's no x squared okay right
so keep that in your head because
that'll be important let's get into
general form
so please squared plus sorry minus PS
okay now stop remember I just told you
this is a parameter right and the
parameter has to exist they have to be
some solutions for this right so if
there are solutions to this what does
that mean about its discriminant if a
quadratic has expensive if it's got
solutions this
it has to be greater than equals 0 right
because if it's negative right
there are no roots no solutions to this
equation
so mr. P breaks okay all right now the
discriminant is b squared minus 4ac but
be careful because this is a quadratic
in P not next what's B it's B is minus s
okay be careful now I know in this case
I'm squaring it doesn't matter okay but
that coefficient is there it's important
okay
so B squared is that minus 4a is equal
to its monic okay and C is equal to 2
all right so now x squared minus 8
greater than 0 okay let's do you see
what just happened
okay now we're back and where we started
okay now some people would just graph
this but you know it's pretty simple
expert minus 8 was down below and I want
the positive positive okay so if you
want to there's minus 8 so that's my
minus 2 root 2 here's my 2 root 2 okay
and I want where it's above so that's
this part is part just like here okay so
therefore
okay now which method do you like which
one do you think is short up mmm the
second that's probably marginally short
I think okay I'm very very badly moving
with one or two lines however the
disadvantage is that it's kind of like
well where do we pull this out from why
did we even do this it's a little less
obvious than well look I looked at the
graph and these are the parts that work
in these parts that don't okay however I
think you got a no vote okay some time
method one's better sometimes minutes
two is better so
significantly sir so you don't want to
lock yourself into I always do it this
way and then you'll meet some question
with your other ways better did you like
okay okay